welcome to this video playmobil mobile
okay so when do we get in yellow with
age three yeah I'm always amazed how
many people play those incorrect
sacrifices it's really amazing it's
really just a pawn for nothing but ok
and blitz chess we know the deal they
even got that played in a tournament
came once against me grandmaster ian
rogers went for that and he also was
just a pawn down and losing he got away
with the drawer somehow but the position
itself was absolutely absolutely
terrible him for a very long time ok is
so hard to play at him I can also i can
really just take that's not it not not
bad really
the only advantage of this this kind of
line in a blitz game is that blacks play
is very simple to conduct I mean it's
not good but it is easy to play just try
to get something on the queenside
because that's the only only kind of
idea that you have so night over to see
for be good maybe Madison would be sad
baby Quincy to that night does not
deform maybe I can prepare you five at
this also on just you five maybe yeah I
guess if you take sick night cheeks so
not reacting in any way push-up g5 then
okay it's d six-week really weak okay
let's see what happens night over to see
four would be brilliant and thick trying
for trying for that
maybe f5 now can cover this though or
may I think I'll cover it Queen B 6 baby
can go Queen B 6 mm technically 94 queen
bee three maybe maybe okay I don't have
to go night safari immediately I can
play improving moves okay
soon what watch here rucca three I
probably have to play
so he got a pawn back and now how do we
get to his King down 95 or we're tough
now 95 wasn't clear to me you how to
play this attack with g four maybe even
aw i didn't play that the best way
possible of course you shouldn't have
gotten even even to this but still
cannot believe it should be any good so
um yeah looking at this annoyed
that's really wrong on air for that it's
always kind of in the in this line of
fire of the Queen really really bad yeah
that act that I got into this position
I thought rook e1 and also much better
but okay so what happens here maybe this
one is gone Goo cage for but g3 rook h5
rookie 3 that looks dangerous it's very
dangerous for black
between g4 maybe or something else some
rookie seven Queen h3 is not working so
let's do that the cheeks r up to 6 h
takes Queen takes Queen g7 ok I've got
check your control key edge here
black resigns i was lucky i mean the
disposition is lost for like you just
lost but i couldn't really put it away
funny enough the engine does not agree
it says night before it's just half a
porn isn't the center exploding and
everything and he's a porn down and
stuff hmm ok it's got to e5 a weekend's
d5 maybe this is this is then that maybe
that's not right then this is the engine
probably just preparing stuff like that
with a simple plus one yeah maybe okay
yeah but that okay maybe this is there
the engine is probably right here g5 is
weak here it gives the remarkable movie
6 and this is just a slight edge for
wide up to something like this they are
hip like s play at d for coming and so
on so if I've was bad and but how do i
improve here maybe this was already not
so great yeah it isn't it isn't that
clear and he I should probably go Bishop
g5 and then 94 now this is this is a a
big big swing now in this position by my
pieces are off side and o queen bee aid
was actually mistake I could've taken
here I was strong
that's a cool pointer by the engine and
tending a 50 hmm okay yeah I thought
just route takes you one and that is ok
I have to check with the night yak we
take this night c 2 nite you form and i
thought this this should be good for
black and red gives black 0.3 maybe i
have just about enough come to play I
it's not really good okay so we got this
the NTA I felt that I should have
dangerous compensation maybe no maybe
not deform yeah one one thing that I
overlooked was that here he's got this
more of course and he's threatening
himself mmm yeah but I got lucky lucky
event here yeah yeah f takes f takes a
caffeine so true check check check now
with the perpetual yeah that was just
you two rookie i was lucky i mean i was
almost winning out of the opening but
played it badly afterwards and let him
back into the game okay thanks for
watching